[TITLE MUSIC PLAYING]
MARISSA: Hi there.
DAVE: Hey.
MARISSA: I'm Marissa.
DAVE: And I'm Dave.
MARISSA: And we work on the
Google Developer Relations
Team.
We're here at the DevZone, which
is the ecosystem for developers
here at Google Cloud Next.
DAVE: Right now at
DevZone Theater,
we're hosting a panel discussion
with the authors of Go.
This is an interactive
session where
people can learn
about the language
and find out what's coming next.
MARISSA: Come with
us as we explore
the rest of the DevZone.
Let's go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Correct.
MARISSA: Correct.
No way.
This is the coolest thing ever.
[CLAPPING]
DAVE: Hey.
SPEAKER 2: Come on.
Say, banana.
Excellent.
Perfect.
We got one.
DAVE: How's it look?
SPEAKER 2: I think it's
looking pretty good, actually.
DAVE: Cool.
I'm getting my snaps on here at
the Network Journey Experiment,
where we're showcasing the
speed and breadth of Google's
worldwide network.
What's going on
here, [INAUDIBLE]??
SPEAKER 2: Well, exactly.
So we're demonstrating here
how Google's investment
in infrastructure
allows our customers
to move their data
around the world
without having to access
the public internet.
It's fast and it's secure.
DAVE: And what does taking
selfies have to do with it?
SPEAKER 2: Taking selfies--
so just like when
you travel and you
get stamps on your
passport, we're
actually taking the data
that makes up your picture.
And as it passes through
these different regions
and these data centers, we
stamp it with that location.
So when it comes back
around to the destination
where you took these
pictures, then we
have actual proof that your data
moved through all these data
centers.
DAVE: That's really cool.
Has my picture made it
around the world yet?
SPEAKER 2: Ah, let's see.
Indeed it has.
DAVE: All right.
Looking good.
SPEAKER 2: None
the worse for wear.
DAVE: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARISSA: Hey Fran,
how's it going?
FRAN: Hi, I'm good, thank you.
MARISSA: Thanks so much
for talking with me today.
Could you share a little bit
of what you and your team
are up to here in the DevZone.
FRAN: So I'm from the Developer
Relations Ecosystem team,
and we are informing people here
about the different community
programs that we have
in the area of cloud.
MARISSA: Awesome.
So what type of programs
do you have that people
can take advantage of?
FRAN: So we basically
have three programs.
So it's the Google Developer
Expert, the ambassador
in a specific area
of technology,
we have the Google
Developer Groups.
Those are local meetups that you
can go to all over the globe.
And we also have the
Women Tech Makers.
That's a program that
increases diversity.
MARISSA: So
specifically there are
programs that people
can take advantage
of in different communities
all over the globe.
FRAN: Yes.
You can basically-- everywhere
you go, you can go to a meetup,
you can meet Google
developer experts
and talk to them about
your area of interest.
MARISSA: Awesome.
Thank you so much for your time.
FRAN: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE: It's 3:14
here in the DevZone,
and that means it's pi time.
We're celebrating because
a fellow Googler of mine,
Emma Haruka Iwao, recently
broke the Guinness World
Record for number
of digits of pi
calculated, using cloud
computing for the first time,
to compute 31.4
trillion digits of pi.
That's a lot of pi.
I'm going to get
my celebration on.
[MUMBLING HUNGRILY]
That's math-a-licious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARISSA: Hi there.
I'm here with Paris at one
of the community corners.
Hey, Paris, how's it going?
PARIS: It's going good.
How are you, Marissa?
MARISSA: I'm good.
What do you do here?
PARIS: I am a Google Cloud
open source strategist.
I work on upstream Kubernetes.
I'm a co-chair of the
special interest group
for contributor experience.
MARISSA: And what makes
Kubernetes unique,
do you think?
PARIS: The community,
definitely.
I think we have
one of the largest
contributing communities.
And I think it's
important to get customers
to participate in that.
And that's why I'm here today.
MARISSA: Awesome.
And what have you been
doing while you've
been here at the DevZone?
PARIS: Oh, playing arcade games.
It's been wonderful.
Watching awesome speakers, and
meeting awesome contributors.
It's been great to have
all of this in one spot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE: We showed
you just a few of
the cool interactive experiences
here at Google Cloud Next.
But you don't have to be here
in person to check this out.
You can visit all of
these experiences and more
at g.co/showcase.
MARISSA: In addition,
we're right in front
of Hands-On Labs.
You don't need to
be here to do that.
You can do it right
now with Qwiklabs.
Get certified, learn all
about Google products,
and get started today.
DAVE: And be sure to subscribe
to the Google Cloud Platform
YouTube channel.
MARISSA: Thank you so much for
joining us here at the DevZone.
We really appreciate it.
Have a great day.
DAVE: See you.